time payments tycoons now the way time
payments work time is just an amazing
overpayments they call them time
payments because it's payments you know
over time but any loan works like this
basically if you borrow some money you
can pay it back over a period of time am
I getting my car a house when we buy a
house usually give a special name a
mortgage right how's this work okay live
been doing that um Johnny right poor
Johnny poor poor cancerous Johnny okay
IRA talk about his superannuation fund
okay so I know the last thing we saw
about it was that he was trying to get a
certain amount and it just it just
didn't wasn't working for him or he
needed like some amazing interest rate
which was impractical so instead of
baking all those hurt on a super scheme
Johnny's going to borrow some money
you know how much did we say I think we
said 50 grand was how much was after
right so she can borrow some money uh
and he you know he works out that he
could repay let's just let's just say um
ten grand a year okay so let's just say
now if we just said that and that was
all right suppose you get some you know
some really nice cream with really deep
pockets and just gave him an
interest-free loan okay how long would
it take him to repay not a complicated
question five years right so that'll be
really nice except most I have friends
who are willing to give us interest-free
loans even the best loans that you can
get in this country which are hex loans
they still get they go up at like CPI to
keep up with inflation right so here's
the reality if he's going to borrow
money they're going to charge an
interest right now when you get when you
borrow money the interest rate is never
as good as when you're investing with it
right
we really like 8% which is actually not
bad as an interest rate right but he's
borrowing it's far more likely to be
something like 15% if that's ridiculous
at twice as much well [ __ ] the real
world actually if you're if you're dumb
enough to get credit card debt it's
going to be like 20% plus okay so don't
never use credit cards for acting
credits that's me that I do
all right so 50% per annum again let's
just consider for the sake of simplicity
let's think about it all just annually
later on we're going to change it to
different time periods but let's just
consider that on this amount he makes
his payment once a year and whoever's
many own money charging interest once in
here
so my question my first question is how
much will he repay after the first five
years reason why I'm interested in this
question is because we said if it was
interest rate you'd be able to get rid
of a lot in five years okay well what
difference does add in this interest
rate the five years what difference is
so in much the same way as your
superannuation we're going to start by
just building it from scratch and then
hopefully the series again it's going to
be a GP will come out we'll understand
where it cable okay so before we set
things like after the first year and
after such as such an amount of time
let's try and be a little more concise
about it let's say let him now owing
after now what time period what time
units we were just four years for now
right just make sure you take note of
this right I'm after n years we will do
the general case first let that amount
thee a to the N dollars okay so you can
see I'm trying to borrow from our Series
in sequence language we usually use T of
n right as in the end time so this is
the
and amount that's left remain so what
will a 1 B equal to just after the first
year after n years 1 year okay
how much is he going to be left with
well we start with the 50 grand right at
the end of the first year is going to
make his repayment but the bank or
whoever's giving the loan is also going
to charge interest now let's just think
for a second which do you think will
happen first it's kind of like a basic
color casinos right so the house always
wins
so interest always gets applied first
all right even if you're like no way
I'll pick one day earlier than ever that
well charge interest one day earlier
okay so what we're going to do is
there's the original method so the
interest gets applied and interest is
15% so that's the 0.15 right so to get
the amount now it's going to be yeah
that's right
1.15 yeah that's the amount interest has
been applied and then it makes his
repayment sad okay so this is how much
we're going now after one year now after
the next year what happens a whole year
passes and nothing actually takes place
and then he's about to make a secondary
payment but of course what happens
before that it gets charged interest
right so I'm going to take this whole
thing in fact I'm going to write aim one
right and I'm going to apply interest to
it just like I applied it to the
beginning level one point one and then
he makes its repayment that okay so just
expanding that out a little bit
okay we get the idea and you can see as
well the GP is starting to form okay now
we're not quite there I'm going to do
one more and then I'm going to try and
generalize from there okay so let's do a
three which is a two times the interest
- the repayment is after the third so
again I'm going to have everything x one
four one five that was here okay so I've
got 50 grand and that's going to now
have three Lots then I've got this ten
gram which was what did this correspond
to by the way that was the first
repayment right one five squared this is
the second repair and is the most recent
one okay now I think this is probably
enough to actually work out well okay
what is this thing going to look like
more generally speaking so if I could
factorize this I think the series will
become a bit more obvious this guy at
the front he saw it doesn't belong right
i he's different from all of these guys
these guys have the common factor this
comes from what we started with what
loan we took out it could be anything
that we could be like five hundred
thousand dollars not like that right so
I'm going to leave it at the front oh
it's only fifty thousand and now I'm
going to take I'm going to do two things
over here so just watch because we're
doing one step I'm going to take out the
factor of 10,000 and don't forget where
these numbers are coming from right so
the 10,000 here is the repayment maple
and as i factor out the Cu T I'm also
going to put it in a more normal water
remember we saw before you know it's
more ordinary for us to think in terms
of series that get bigger okay so here's
my ten thousand at the front and two
negative two all of these negatives here
become positive following my first time
will be this one so that's one the next
one will be this one point one five and
my last point is going for five square
okay now because of the question I just
asked how much we ever being owing in
five years right so we actually could
just do this manually do the fourth one
and then do the fifth one okay but I
could just as easily have changed this
question and say well how much after
fifty years if you still had a loan at
that point right so instead of just
going every step manually I'm going to
try and go from here the third one to
the influent I'm going to try and
generalize you now pay really careful
attention get out another color for this
what are the important pieces here we've
got the original amount that was over
maybe would help you to label this rate
original amount then you've got this one
point one five which appears many many
times and that comes from the interest
rate then you have this 10 grand
factorize out front and the reason why
it's a negative ten greater as a
personal rule during superannuation
question right is because it's repay
it's try to get rid of this thing right
eventually these two things are going to
be equal so that's the payment now if
you remember in the super education and
eurasian questions we have four
quantities right that we could muck
around with i've got three of them
what's the fourth one it's how long are
we going for right in this case this
specific one is this three here and
where it appears is be carefully two
places right
number one it appears here so I just
there's the time but it also appears
over here except this is not n this is n
minus 1 right so this is this is this
one okay you see this one's always going
to be one less than this one because of
what we said before that the interest
always gets a fire before the repayment
because the husband's wins right so this
will be a ten this will be a 10-4 now
we're ready to generalize okay what do
we got here the original amount owed
multiplied by how many what's the
interest rate well however many years
you've had the light fall okay but over
here on 10 grams
there's our payment and how many terms
will I have I'll start with one and then
I'll go to 1.15 the very last one will
be one point one five to the power of n
minus one
okay so before I actually answer the
question how much will he repay in five
years we can do asked our you know our
GP magic here to actually work out what
this is equal to even though it's an
indeterminate number of terms right so
again get out your different color so
this is a GP where we have three pieces
that define a GP right they are the
first term the common ratio and how many
terms there are what's the first term
just one
the ratio is from the interest rate how
many terms are there this is kind of
1.15 ^ 0 right so if I start at 0 and I
ended up M minus 1 then in total there
should be in turn is that okay and you
can sort of test that out
when you look up here this is a 3 right
I've got 3 times 1 2 3 and then the
previous one where wasn't over here hey
- I've got my 1 2 terms there okay
whenever you're unsure you like this n
or n plus 1 or minus 1 just just count
what - an example that you know in
concrete terms so I will say there are n
terms you could say any and if you want
but that's kind of redundant on it
alright so now that I know all the
pieces I can say what's the sum of that
part so I've got my 50,000 and this part
over here I have my negative 10 grams
times what so remember back think back
to your sum of a GP you're going to have
a which is just 1 times R to the power
of M
there's our art and there's out here
minus 1 all divided by r minus 1 right
ok oh by the way do you have to write
that one day probably not but I'm doing
it so that I know exactly where this
thing comes from what all my pieces
there it's not just coming out all right
let's just simplify this
now you stood among you will notice that
I've got my 1.15 to power of n over here
I've also got one over here right it
appears in both places so I can simplify
further than this I've got a number here
and a fraction over there I can get
these together right
probably the easiest way since I've got
that on a factor 4 1 5 if I multiply
this part of the equation by 0.15 on
0.15 I haven't changed this term over
here it's still the same time right but
now this fraction in that fraction can
talk to each other take a little sip by
that
mm-hmm you could get your calculator up
if you wanted to but you also could
think alright I've got 15 here and I've
got a 5 there 5 by 15 is 75 right and
then have a look at how many displace
you got here how many you've got over
here what's it going to be equal to it's
a bit square so it's between 10 to 20%
right so you make it much more that's
gonna be sewing 500 right so no tricks
like that you're going to get your
calculator out this left-hand fraction
is 7,500 lots of that guy right - 10,000
lots of the same thing and then what's
the double negative plus 10,000 over
here all over point one five right one
last step I can actually put these two
together I'll put the 10,000 out the
front since has a positive so I've got
10,000 yup
- so 500 minus 10,000 okay now what we
could do something a little neater with
this decimal but I'm happy with that
that was sort of content because I just
got this end left over here which in a
second I'm going to substitute for five
to actually solve my question just
before I do that I just wanted to draw
you into the fact that I'm often this
will be your first part of like a
three-part series of sequence question
you'll say show that a to the N is equal
to and then they'll say squat there you
go prove that okay so you're going to
have to go through all of this business
they'll give you like two or three marks
and what they're looking for you to do
is build it from scratch okay so that's
why I was slowly before you remember I
showed you that formula I said this is
kind of useful but don't use it okay
because you're going to have to do this
anyway
all right you really need to know how to
do it well okay now I'll build the
general term I can find out what the
fifth one is right to get calculator app
let's say
a five which is actually answering the
question Ellis hit me in the first place
this what do you get
we have a number anyone 33,000 and check
out yeah and how much five cents that
could make the difference okay all right
now so let's just stop bagging work out
what is this medium
this means it after five years I'll pay
10 grand every year what kind of debt
has he actually made in his loan adds up
not very much okay and this is what
happens when you get a loan then you've
got interest rates and bits which is not
unrealistic okay so if we had an
interest free loan the whole thing would
be gone but as it is he hasn't even got
halfway okay
so I wonder what the next logical
question is if this is how paragraph
after five years then how long is it
going to take me to pay off the whole
lot how long's it going to take me to
work out pay off the whole lot Johnny
anyway okay so we've actually done most
of the legwork to work that out the
important part is this one okay so when
you have a go when you solve it and see
where we go from there